okay
tuesday night blitz chess
swiss for those who are members of the
team
all right let's let's have some fun here
three two nine rounds
see who we get like over the board chest
but not
all we can do is focus on each round no
rush one game at a time
what are we gonna get all right let me
let me d4 with d5
against sir strife okay
nice and easy step by step
how aggressive are you gonna be with the
c pawn
not budging with the c pawn
one or two steps none of the above
all right so it's clear
this bishop wants to fianchetto
i want my bishop out and about my bad
guy
only then e6
you take me maybe
um i'm actually recalling playing i
think
against a longer game
against a human that later turned out to
be a
cheater account i believe where i kind
of got smashed with this idea
with doubled doubled pawns and
computer ended up doing something with
uh these pawns and i uh
i don't know i'm trying to recall how
that game went
okay i'm not so sure about taking the
bishop i i prefer to uh
just back off maybe
maybe give me this file for as long as
this tension remains one thing that i
can
say is uh not have to worry so much
about the c pawn contributing there's
more work to be done
in order for c4 to be played also
i don't know if i really want to play
this because i would open up this
bishop's eyes along the main diagonal
so let's just stick with knight to d7
trying to neutralize this knight his one
big
big jump is under control now somewhat
could still go there um
here's another thing initially i was
thinking about going here but
if i go here and the knight jumps in
then i cannot take with the knight i end
up in a fork
so
i don't want to put my bishop in the i
don't want to set my bishop up for that
potential tactic i want to be in a
position to take the night when it
arrives there and
i think i want to do that right away as
otherwise he could be glued in with this
move
maybe oh i'm always talking about that
bishop
that c pawn in case it moves
all right i am officially up a piece big
blunder there
queen e2 and only then that advance now
my bishop's under
under attack i was saying i was going to
take the knight
if it arrives there i don't think
things really change so much
just because i'm up a piece yeah i think
it's just all the more
useful to trade away and move forward
um actually i'm on the rook
whoops yeah that's a reason to have not
uh
taken the knight i could have captured
the rook he could still do it
i'm okay i know i'm not making the best
with this sequence but we are
trading and i'm up upon and the exchange
at the end of the day
so can't really complain too much
also down on the clock
half open file peel open this file for
my rook
i yeah i mean i should really never get
into this situation where
i even have to play up the exchange
instead of up a clean
piece but here we are
let's go queen b2 hits a lot of stuff
queen gonna get trapped
nah
you're here here re1 is there
i feel like in a way you know just a
quick a quick rough thought
before i go in there i'm thinking myself
i'm already up the exchange if it really
came down to
me having to give up my queen for a rook
maybe maybe things are still
gonna work out for me in the end
i'm being gifted some pieces in this
game
two miners
let's get at the back rank
we'll take with check
and just remove any nonsense make sure
that pawn is long gone
and we got rook e1 nearby
trades one quick check
before i move that rook forward this
guy's unprotected no way to take
advantage of it though
and no way to to guard
the rook along the diagonal so more
material
it has to be given up main two threat
and we should have mate shortly okay now
they resigned all right good game sir
strife
round one is in the books you can late
join
up until round four
if it's round five that's that's the
cutoff
for beyond the halfway point
no light joining allowed so when you
light join i think you end up getting a
half point maybe some of you have
already done that
um
yeah there's these light yeah see
there's light joiners so it's very
common
so feel free to late join if you would
like i'll throw out the link once more
one more time once more time
there you go
join the team the team is right here
and you should see it listed this is
live
when it's in orange or excuse me the
orange means that it's upcoming or
ongoing
all right so back to the swiss
and let's jump in on a game that's
currently going on between these two
doctor of love versus
remy okay things are looking
good white is up a pawn
and maybe it will oh i was thinking
after this the rook has to take but then
that pawn would bolt yeah that wreck
needs to stay right there
oh okay it's
okay this is this is being lined up i
was thinking it's white's move uh oh
the old deflection tactic was there that
f4 was not needed
this is the threat
kick the king away from the night remy's
down on the clock
and gets out of that deflection tactic
this is a tough pawn to work around this
rook is the
there's cl it's close to mate if the
king went there oh there's a fork there
now this is this is not uh
i think the rook is the one piece that
likes blockading they passed upon
least
plenty of ways to do it now for white
just to be a trading machine
okay black resigned that one view the
tournament still two games going
let's check out this one
um which way is each side going
okay black is going this way
yeah black is in trouble
black is losing
lamp lamp nick versus b brian
okay the pawns are all scooped up
black hoping for stalemates at this
point okay black resigned
final game okay that was the last one
there
okay so 62 are now in there
how about the browns i see i see you in
the chat yeah i know
said i was a legend the other day in
this stream get out
no way
all right under 20
how many have late joined well first of
all how many
have a full point this guy gotta buy
in round one we paired up soon
i don't think you get more than a buy
all right so we got 20
21 with one point a good chunk with uh
half point draws or late joiners okay
shitako
familiar a familiar opponent
all right what do we want to do what do
we want to play
let's go with uh let's go with b3
make make naka proud right he's a fan of
b3
the speed chess champ
speed chess champ no magnus versus
nakamura
mvl said no no no no no
not so fast man
i have something to say
all right
e5 is the big square that comes to mind
in this
setup every one of my moves so far is
directly or indirectly influencing that
square
trying to remove a piece that's
controlling e5 everything is focused on
this
is this where it ends can i put no more
pieces on e5
i could play d5 d4 let's go with d4
not really concerned that my bishop's
eyes will be shut down
along the main diagonal
okay or out of a pin
um what about
what about a chop right now
yeah i'll chop
my knight here so i i kind of
have an eye on one of these two moves
i'm not sure when i want to pull the
trigger on either one
i don't have enough support for e4 just
yet
if queen e2 knight before it's a little
irritating defending c2
could always fall back do i want to give
up the bishop for tonight
i should have i i was just ready to say
maybe i should have uh
considered taking the knight with my
bishop first all right now i can now i
could strike in it
i think i think this makes a whole lot
of sense right now within this structure
i don't think i'm i don't think i'm
better i i really don't think i'm uh
yeah i i don't i don't think that i'm
better here
um before this capture i was thinking
about queenie too maybe
maybe that but i i'm liking more queen
on c2
maybe maybe we chopping at the bishop
i want to be careful i you know if i if
i initiate this exchange then my queen's
post will be brought into question so
i think it makes more sense to maintain
the tension
i'd like to see this capture right
because that improves my knight and then
this pawn isn't so happy
mine's isolated so
we both do well i believe in short to
keep the tension
and deciding now whether or not i want
to put a rook on d file c file
either this or this
uh or e4s is running through my mind
kind of like e4
but why
not really sure
okay e4 is committal
i could go with the non-committals
what would i like to have happen here
dark square bishop exchange a bish
a knight on e knight on c5 that seems
difficult to pull off
i could try and close things down with
c5 that might be
i'll give that a try
here i have b4 i could maintain this so
i'm basically trying to play against
this guy i
i mean it could still have some activity
along this diagonal
um yeah i'll go for this space
let's start with this now that bishop
will definitely have some activity
and when bishop a6 is in there
where does my rook go
i feel like the e file is best let me
keep this option open i have to be a
little concerned
maybe with the bishop d3 that can sting
this file opens up and i end up in some
fork
well let's centralize at this point yeah
this i still have b4
maybe i'm misplaying it a bit rook to b8
could be annoying
okay now let's go with this i have
different i have a different way
i can be defending against c5
i could play bishop to d4
so what am i what am i really looking to
do here do i really want to capture on
d5 i don't
i don't think so this pawn is
unprotected as well
timely timely and timely knight jump and
striking at c6 and maybe something else
all right 48 seconds each
all right start with that
bishop on f6 i play e5
maybe even a queen on c3 could be could
be a little fun
queen on c6 also
okay f6
thinking maybe a little bit more about
capturing now
i like that there's this uh square here
also
this you have to take with the pawn
otherwise i get that pawn
yeah i think it's okay to capture here
this move takes away
two very good squares from the miners
um
their queen is restricted my knights
need to do something else i mean they're
kind of
ridiculous aren't they they're pretty
ridiculous
what are they doing contributing not at
all
in this position let's jump around we
got some
sweet squares oh rick rook to c6 was a
move
if i was looking to be a little greedy
but yeah these knights over here look
look pretty good let's jump in here i'm
i want to get rid of that
that bishop i think i don't know
f5 was looking good too but maybe i end
up parking both
both nights i gotta watch my time both
knights on f5
g6 at the end of the day
we'll go on thought about this but this
guy kind of
still scares me he's around time and
time
they just barely pulled that move off
wow they are living off of oh they mouse
slipped
and when their moves there right at the
end i think when they captured my rook
it said
two seconds right on the nose barely
pulled that one off
shitaka okay good game down to the wire
there
really just felt equal right around here
i don't know that's my assessment what's
the computer think
likes black a tick yeah didn't feel like
i had anything
okay back to tournament land round three
starting after these six games are over
oh
what's happening here against i'm a
kitty
uh black okay this isn't
oh okay this guy's going this way
gonzo all right black's gonna get this
one
i'm i'm a kitty is gonna get this one
so no upset in that one let's check out
a different one what one's interesting
this one's not too interest okay that's
the same game
what's going on here it's a lot of pawns
uh queens are off
yeah this looks it's opposite-colored
bishops they're all drawn right
not here oh you could play bishop there
land the fork
okay black's gonna get this one here
yeah time is not going to be a problem
we got the increment
and what about this one okay this one's
this one's gonzo too
so i'm expecting round
two to wrap up shortly
hello brid bridgen it's going all right
okay that's
that's it for round two it's in the
books
who's this the kid who plays the kid
nice name
all right um i missed some alerts here
twerp thank you for the prime resub
two months in a row dj double m thank
you for the host
mermaid thank you for the tier one resub
seven months in a row
very low sodium thank you for the tier
one resub 34 months in a row
mark mr snatch pedo thank you for the
tier 1 resub 33 months in a row
you say how's it going my man it's going
pretty good
thank you for gifting subs
smko thank you for uh
the gifted sub okay
i'm all caught up and
let's see what we're gonna do here for
this round three facing
facing the cfo
oh oh that was just a
countdown not to lose my clock would
simply start
after that okay this is not an arena
look at one of the spectators here the
fred defense
the fred defense okay i like that the
pieces are moving much smoother
for me
i like it all right
let's go here
all right you're just gonna dive right
in i'm gonna chop
chop and challenge what's this
pawn in my house i'll try and do
something about that
to be careful this guy's unprotected
so we wouldn't we don't want to allow
some kind of queen
a4
all right let's castle right now yeah
now if night here i could consider a
choproni
i don't know if this is really the right
idea i i think i'm supposed to move the
bishop and not
be capturing like this all right
um this looks unusual
but i may do it
yeah i'm going to go here
i'm kind of giving giving away a lot
with this move
i'm basically saying that i'm going to
try this to put pressure on this pawn
and then maybe they do this and my
bishop is
is free to move about on its natural
diagonal
uh what if they don't cave they try and
maintain this point
well let's see maybe that's what they're
going for
seems like a pretty good idea
all right
all right they're doing it i think this
is a very good idea makes my bishop look
ridiculous
um
here here here bishop takes bishop here
do i give up the exchange
could be a little fun subjectively
certainly bad
look at look at these nights
oh i like the white knight much better
than the black knight here um
all right i'm not really a fan of giving
up a pawn and
trying for some bishop h3 move
here here here
and maybe i would have something some
play on the light squares
i mean i likely would
but they don't have to even take the
rook they could just say i'm
i'm i'm full i've taken upon and that's
all i want
all right yeah this was this was not
very good opening play don't try this at
home
i'm kind of looking to close things down
maybe
or do i just get rid of this knight
first and then play d6
maybe that's that's the best approach
they try and support it i can maybe go
here and then play d6 as soon as e4 is
in d4 as a whole
maneuver like this tries to take
advantage of that gap
instead of shutting my bishop in with d6
they're in the tank they better not be
listening
i might throw a stream tactic your way
watch out for the stream tactics
i haven't forgot about them
stream tactics
stream tactics okay
can this point be maintained if i throw
a little a little
heat on that guy let's let's see what
are you doing about that
maybe a little too soon okay i mean you
could maintain b4 with rook b1 but then
at least i have the file
maybe this is giving me
a little something on the queen side
why could take here and solve all my
problems
that'd be nice queen could see bishop
could see
all right now my rook says wait a second
wait can i not take this pawn now
why not i got i got three on this point
now
i think they're missing that uh this
rook is around
out of out of nowhere out of right field
he has emerged patrolling the fifth
stable
take with the night
no i thought i didn't like this night
and i was welcome to a night exchange
and now i'm not all of a sudden
what's keeping me from that in this
instance i don't want this bishop's eyes
to open up so easily
i also i'm looking at d4 with tempo and
then maybe d5
so that's why all right so now i could
shut things down
yeah i like e4 a lot this guy's
the main thing you know i just don't
want him to see
so easily i guess i have to block in
this guy if
this guy wants to see this knight is
kind of stupid
my rick was under fire i didn't have to
move it
okay tell you what we're gonna put the
bishop right here
and he's going to just act like a tall
pawn for a little while
and just a little pawn there
happy little pawn try and get rid of
their best piece
i like that maybe a saccharony
all right let's flick in a flight square
flick in a flight
prepare to double on the a file
oh i'm in a pin i don't like that
let's try again let's go here and then
double
both living off the increment this is a
hole
so this kind of maneuver maybe i i could
sneak that in fast
where are you going tonight oh my bishop
you see they're floundering
tell you what let's get this kind of
construction in
okay this knight i think just needs to
go
play that move no okay let's lock it
down they should have played f5
i think
all right baby step it man baby step it
don't be any
don't be in any rush
i'm on the queen we're making we're
making progress now my bishop's glued in
there
um eeny meeny miny moe
i don't know i think the king is best
there
uh let's crack it open soon
uh i think he's safe is here no no rook
checks with tempo okay
okay we're getting there
you got pins um
oh that's not a freebie
careful now careful
queen's covering that oh
did not see that one coming
oh my rook's hanging
the free rook in the corner don't see it
it's a free rook in the corner they saw
i'm in trouble
got the material back though crazy
bishops
they're like sharks
bishop here rook there getting the queen
take the queen take the rook
holy cow
got oh i had a i had a pin there
run pawn i got a little
too crazy there
oh okay
good game okay that was the final game
yeah
i didn't that wasn't that was a weird
opening
i shouldn't i shouldn't revisit that
opening anytime soon
yeah i seen the chat splendid game
jerry i don't think so
not even close spielman seven thank you
for the tier one resub four months in a
row
uh shiv dragon thank you for the prime
prime sub and aquil angula thank you for
the prime resub
33 months in a row now appreciate your
support
alright so we got 70 in there
i'm a kitty
from leeches okay
let's go with
d4
let's try something different bishop g5
early inbounds okay what can we say
i have a
big eye on this guy what what are you
going to be doing
all right let's put this guy here
i want to keep this guy free just keep
uh
d4 rock solid if it's under fire
yeah black doesn't have an intent any
intention to do that
i'm thinking this is going to be the
play
a knight on f6 that e4 square is looking
pretty good for black
um let's start with this
and i'm keeping open the option for h3
and g4
should this move be played let's see
okay they're not they're not going with
f5 just yet
um could i could i go
i could i could probably go for this
kind of stuff yeah
queen on f3
queen on f3 how's that
hmm
i could consider a break there's a lot
there's a lot of different ideas here
a knight on f6 is easily offset by this
double pawn
um i'm going to give this a try
queen on f3 maybe it's also simply
supporting a knight on f4
where's the break gonna be so actually
queen
queen f3 stops this f5 move all together
okay well if my queen's on f3 my
knight's
not going to go there my queen's not
going to go anywhere else
queen doesn't currently have any safe
square besides this one maybe i should
have
looked at that before playing my last
move
but there's no piece that could attack
her i mean this would be threatening to
win my queen
may have to watch out for that
there could be even some some tricky
things right where
chop chop like like that stream tactic
video if you've seen it chop chop my
queen is hit my rook is going to fall
okay so still gearing up for this
i'm going to flick this in
yeah um okay so what about g4 right now
let's go with g4 g4 is saying a lot
about my king and his
future home that's not going to be on
the king's side
super weakening all right my rook is
happy
so now this idea of a knight getting
into this square isn't uh
i don't know about that anymore now that
the f-pawn isn't there to secure knight
you kind of need two pawns around
if you want to establish a knight in
that e4
square
are there any checks in the position one
but it's not
good black doesn't have any checks
queenside castle e4 i mean things have
opened up
a bit where i think i there's potential
to be
pretty direct there's the potential to
play some pretty direct moves some
forceful moves
do i want to capture that queen
my first thought is to to to duck the
exchange
yeah let's keep the queens on
this move sort of concerns me okay
they're allowing me to play this move
let's castle
now what
okay let's go here
if they strike at this pawn one way or
the other they end up with a split
structure
isolated pawns
okay they're just uh increasing the
pressure on this point oh yeah that
makes
that makes a lot of sense oh their
queen's gonna get trapped though
ooh their queen is trapped
ooh this is gonna hurt
no soup no clean trade
she's cooked
nope nope nope
oop
just duck the queen exchange yeah she
went she's a little too close
i have enough defense i guess we take
with the queen
best spot for the rook is the corner
night is unprotected
how do i break things down
i guess we start here jump jump in with
the knight
all right um we'll take towards the
center still
this guy up here so they have a rook and
a pawn for the queen
knight f4 declined
let's get a flight square for my king no
dark square bishop around
okay with that pawn like still let's
let's play in the center
oh i get the knight with check big
detail right there
could i have taken here i was that was
concerning me a little bit
so remove the glue oh look here
on the bishop
all right let's get rid of that pawn
get out any potential checks there
ready to take the liquid check
and we don't care about losing a pawn
nothing nothing to fear over here with
these guys
we gotta check i only need the strength
of a rook
at that point okay good game i'm a kitty
the queen got a little too
crazy there
um yeah i once more
kind of do not like that uh i was
playing the opening there let's check
out another one here
be brian against violin and viola
be brian is up a piece here
a knight versus pawn but soon a full
night
just go hunting take here
yeah that's the cleanest
it takes pawn there is good too all
right white is gonna get this one maybe
we
how's that other one doing going
this one here fishy's
sushi
yeah this one black
all right yeah that's a good way to get
out of the pin black's gonna get this
one
i guess we'll just stay here
i don't think anything's going to be too
exciting on this one
interested in seeing the standings maybe
am i going to play in the winter
marathon yeah maybe
when is it it's happening this weekend
yeah i know sorry about the browns last
night i know it was
it was a it was a very good game 12
touchdown game
a lot of action
uh torquay tv thank you for the tier one
resub
12 months in a row 13 total now
appreciate it man
what's the winter marathon's time
control trio
uh how long did it take me for to get
approved as a lead chess streamer
i don't um
i think i might have been proved
automatically i don't think
i no
i don't know if i'm right about that
not very long is my
my quick answer without thinking too
much
so i was already i was already you know
it was
i was already streaming for a while
it's kind of it's established you know
i think it's been close to 10 years
been streaming
so
oh what happened here by the way
okay um
oh yeah a rook
fell and now the tables have turned
uh can white win this one uh
who knows what's gonna happen at this
point
you could be tricky if the rook goes in
the corner after the there's a
possibility for this
like rook here rook here and if the rook
yeah it's gone now rook oh there was a
rook check and the bishop would have
would have fallen look right now there
it is
ah down goes the bishop the tables turn
approaching move 100
this one's still not over get over there
king blockade
you're not there though in time
okay this is probably the final game
imagine that other one is over
okay over black resign on that one okay
so we are four rounds in
it's got the question mark nobody knows
what rating okay so how many with four
three with four
three and a half a bunch of threes
these are all the participants some have
gone into pause mode
all right let's see we get next well
he's in pause i'm going to get this guy
community
community chess 01 all right
let's see if i can play a good opening
okay let's let's just go with c6 this
time
and have too good at time with e5
all i'm looking to do with c6 is
maintain a pawn on d5
maybe in some cases i i take a pawn and
try and hang on to it
not the case here
a6 i don't know if it's good but i
i go i go with a6 to uh have this square
for my rook
and sometimes i would say this
sarcastically but um
because normally a very
weird looking move but i want to be
prepared to meet queen b3 with defense
of b7 um
queen moves to try and defend the b7 are
subjected to knight attack rook attack
on the c file
okay so now i mean
once i put my knight on this square
queen b3 could be could be met
conveniently with knight to a5
and now that there's this pawn on a4 i
don't have
any concern of let's say queen a4 check
so i like seeing a4 for
that reason no fear of lines with queen
a4 check and also
uh this square being a hole
you know my knight has
his eye on the b4 square so i might as
well
play the move i said i was gonna play
um
i was just thinking oh is bishop b5
check can be played here
uh no that's not happening
queen [ __ ] the queen could get trapped
queen b4 and she's
toast i i could
i could be more direct actually e5
queen b4 e5
yes so she has to go back home is my
knight out of play now he's on the edge
he's not is excited
about the c4 and b3 squares there might
be a fork
nearby queen d2
okay so where 10 moves in i'm happy
about my position
a4 seems misplaced
um a6 is purposeful knocks out two
squares from these guys
i wasn't really intending i think a4 was
played to stop b5 but i really had no
intention of playing b5
here here or here to preserve my bishop
in the event of knight to h4
now i'll go here first get one step away
if knight here i could maybe be a little
annoying
with bishop to g4 if white really wants
to they could
hunt my bishop but they have to make
several concessions on the king side for
that
and i'll maintain a solid structure
over the whole board really
this is my primary focus to maintain
a solid king side structure so he's nice
and cozy
i'm expecting these next few moves for
me to flow pretty
pretty smooth logical stuff
nothing uh too sophisticated here queen
on b6 work on c8
yeah um i've played here before
but i i really don't mind uh
initiating this exchange i know i helped
to clean out a tick
but i'm okay with that so rook on f
to c1 and there's the fork
so this guy if you're going to contest
the c file
nope so the fork is
official
symmetrical structure on king on the
king side in the center
main differences here queen side
structure
that fork isn't going anywhere by the
way any
it's not going away by the way
i would prefer to see a rook move before
grabbing one of the rooks
that way white wastes a move i like the
idea of flicking in a flight square as
well so let me do that
trying to squeeze the most out of this
situation i'm in it's tempting to want
to take a rook but
i think it's best to not
take right away
for tempe reasons
okay we could still play this game
something i i may have to be on the
lookout for is this and the queen's
attacking the knight
um but i mean i
could i could take here with chuck so i
think we're still going to play this
little who's who's
more patient game um
all right so now i'm getting a full full
rook
maybe maybe more because this i could
take like that
and then there'd be a knight okay i
don't have to i don't have to run it
like this now so i could play
just improving my night getting in a
spot to liquidate
liquidate and be up a rook versus a pawn
i'll start right here i could go hunting
for pawns but i prefer to put my queen
on a stable square
where she's gluing everything together
everything's defended
and just look for a queen trade let's
put this guy up here
queen on this square could be good too
not now
let me uh let me just back out for a
second let me try
something else let's control both files
let my rook do some probing
grab a pawn
all right let's take here
got this square covered
time no time okay
yeah this is the one move that's out of
out of place i feel
pawn on a4
so do without that i think we're
gonna be in a much different situation
there
i don't want to do that okay six games
still going let's check out
not that one just what a full piece
okay what about this one here the little
gm
the little gm against lamp nick
are things looking here this pawn's
close to queening
be a little careful i stopped oh
ooh white's gonna no king could always
play here
reply to a check
yeah black black's gonna get this one
you can't get him but this guy's
promoting a check
first okay black's gonna take this
let's check out another game okay there
is white resigned that one
one game going this one here
uh white's going this way okay we'll
just watch the
this one play to mate i guess the final
game
anaximander thank you for the tier one
resub eight months in a row
raffle link thank you for the tier one
resub nine in a row
ten total and wayne
beam thank you for the tier one resub
seven months in a row seven
total you add hey jerry hope you're
healthy and well
thanks man i'm doing i'm doing all right
hope you're doing well as well
all right let's see the mate
get them on the edge
there it is
and mate next
boom all right final one
round five is in the books this guy is
still in pause mode
he's gone only wanted to play four
he's out of here all right so we got
five
two three four five six players with
four
is your top 20.
let's go through them all still
okay see we get round six coming up
um i don't know not him
could be the little gm the casual player
the kid who plays the kid
doctor okay the casual player
let's play f4
all right
let's try this now that i know this
guy's
gonna go here i don't have to worry
about
any any pressure by the bishop on b4
so b4 says what
open a door for the bishop and grab some
space on the queen side maybe be
annoying to the knight
make sure this rook doesn't come to life
c4
let's go with c4
yeah challenge their strongest pawn
okay maintain tension a4
making a lot of pawn moves
five pawn moves think i want to maintain
a pawn on this square
why though
i mean if my idea is to maintain a pawn
there that would mean
giving black a past a pawn past
potentially
connected past pawn
um i don't like a a4 anymore
maybe i just take i helped tonight
why why take you take me let's go here
at the end of the day who would have who
would have thunk it
you just develop a piece
and later you realize oh yeah these are
the reasons why it's
better
still helping their night you take me
help my night
take here take there all right the night
has
made a move what's this guy gonna do now
okay i may want to play this
control the knight might be eyeing up
this square maybe i go baby step
no not like that what about a chop here
very indecisive
not sure what i want to do um
bishop b2
see playing this move knight to b6
concerns me also the clock concerns me
i don't like my structure this just
doesn't feel right
yeah maybe that's why i'm struggling to
find
something here
all right i'm giving up this big square
i realize
yeah it's a big square why'd i do that
exactly i don't know
i was concerned about this in the night
jumping in here that's
that's what it was i don't like my
position
knight on g4 quick jab at e3
it's unprotected
it's a hole all right
the square can be controlled so easily
i have i have a little space here on the
queen side
big deal okay yeah they're trying to
squeeze me here
can't let that pun go any further you've
gone far enough
i don't even know how i follow up here
from being honest
what do i do
i don't want the b file to open up
bishop will have some
some pressure on him pressure on the
pawn or can't go too far
but i don't know yeah queen on a5
the moves seem to be much easier for
black to play
here bishop f5 here knight there trade
light square bishops put the knight back
on e4 and say
say who's the boss all right i guess we
just keep things closed
i don't know
oh you know what bishop here i could
play knight h4
potential pac-man knight if he tries to
do something fancy
still with the discover check i'll lock
it down entirely
let's get this guy here this this
probably shouldn't have been allowed
this
this kind of space i i mean i have some
okay some ideas
here i think i've gained a lot of ground
these last couple moves
um yeah let's let's let's drop a knight
right in the center
what about h3 as well it's tough to kick
my knight away because of this pressure
i have on g6 with h6 in there
so long term you know a rook a knight a
bishop
canal can i'll scoop up that pawn
flight square maybe if i'm feeling a bit
more aggressive g4
i could consider that it is pretty
locked a through d
files are all fixed
this really isn't an option
um still can't play this because my
bishop and knight are there you'd have
to take my knight first
i think i'd be taking uh let's let's get
a little aggressive i think i'd be
taking like this
oh i shouldn't have allowed that move
oh should also not lose on time
yeah i should not have allowed this this
knight to jump in there now they could
kick my knight
oh they're not oh i gotta go so much
faster
shut up and play
man
um whole living off the increment
i'm going to attack my rook
all right
this will take the queen knight here
queen here defend that
don't go don't go too crazy night my
bishop can uh
land a checaroni oh am i threatening
that
oh i would have liked to have calculated
maybe that
whoa that night had a move
how can sting ooh
that hurts
queen's gonzo um
okay good game the casual player
these uh this is not good for me i
i mean what's the computer say i should
play here
it doesn't feel like it's equal i don't
know struggling to find moves
i think once i play d4 there's no way i
could be better
yeah no way all right
yeah this was this was bad giving up
that monster square to
everything okay
back to tournament
what's happening here white's gonna win
that most likely
okay okay there's only one game now
black's gonna take it andrew9
straight to me
there it is okay
round
round seven will start soon okay
30 seconds
have i tried fog of war no
thanks twerp i'm swell
huh
all right doctor of love
all right doctor love
prance okay let's try
latest sicilian already what about d6
try and do something a little different
maybe it still turns into a sicilian
how do i want to set up here i guess i
guess we're going to key in on a square
and go with it
okay they have no intention
of playing d4 here they're going for
some simple
simple setup that can kill me i'm not
careful okay let's go with this
idea i need to make sure d4 is not
played
so as soon as the knight arrives here i
have to dive in
and i'm playing this so that i could
play here without this exchanging my
bishops
so right here right now knight needs to
go here
because if these pawns get exchanged
then this is a
real sore spot my bishop is not around
to conveniently defend this
so when it goes here i'm not obstructing
any
obstructing any of my pawns with my
pieces
this is the only pawn that's obstructed
right now
also i cannot castle
um king side that would drop a pawn
knight here
really not sure how to play these
positions
see if here here i want to be able to
meet f4 with f5 but then
am i not losing this guy
rook to b8
these ideas can happen soon the knight
retreats and then they fight for control
over this square
not sure let's go with rick to b8
maybe rook to b8 in b6
b6 and then uh this this move
they may be ready to play this
maybe i could go here though let's try
that
let's try h4 i i haven't committed
to king side castling just yet
maybe i get the h file or they're going
to shut it down
not a single trade yet
i have checks
no good check in this one but i still
have checks so
maybe tactics are are closer to favoring
me than what
since i have checks and they don't
all right we're definitely taking with a
piece
so right here like these kind of tricks
might already be nearby
right now
here there's there
here there's this which is annoying
or is it can i play a little trickeroni
are we a sneaky guy
oh you have a really good move then i
have that
trickeroni
it's not like a hope chess move it's not
an inferior move
okay so they fell for the trick unless
i'm missing something
this tricky guy okay now i can no longer
rely upon my night
so it's time to flee be satisfied i've
won a pawn remember that i cannot castle
gotta go back
being kicked around now it wasn't the
the greatest pawn to end up winning but
king has no moves only one safe square
for their king maybe that
maybe that factors in
okay what can we do here
i can't castle
this guy's moved this guy's moved
how to improve play in the center play
in the center is the way
made on h2
here we go try to coordinate with this
this guy
okay what do we do
i was thinking i could take with the
knight i can't take with the knight
i gotta take with the pawn
okay
chop
e-files open up and i cannot castle
also bishop f4 is gonna sting if i try
to get on that diagonal
uh i really wasn't sure where i should
go with that bishop
queen here broke on the d file soon
playing too slow as usual it's gonna
come back to bite me
knf8 i think i need to do that soon
i have pressure here
so i can maybe grab here if the knight
moves but i'm
i'm more concerned about my king safety
so i want to get off the e-file
like yesterday you know could put a lot
of a lot of pressure on this guy
that could be painful
yeah let's let's just
you know get out of pins and stuff
all right their clock is running low as
well
how do they like it i've been living out
for the increment for a while now
centralize
i like that they unpinned my night okay
i have a lot of heat
right here a lot of heat i could have
captured it but i just still want to
kind of develop here
don't mind seeing these trades
what about now though
night here we got mate soon huh h1 we
get the exchange
my king is nice and cozy here
give up on the h file let's centralize
push up on save upon
push up on
keep pushing
keep going
got a pivot square bishop's in a pin
they're down on time okay
got the w overall though
not too happy with uh how i'm playing
these openings
the majority of the games they're not
really
going how i'd like them good game
doctor of love let's check out this one
rook and pawn ending
seems close here
balanced with the pawns that white king
is really active
ready to grab that pawn
ooh really here here
now now there is no creating a past pawn
b4 seemed a little
a little odd
all right black has very good
coordination um
still still kind of tricky
the rook can't move without dropping one
of these two oh
could have grabbed that pawn with
check and maybe gun after that guy
he's going back for it now it's defended
time pressure be brian again we're
checking out a lot of
games by b brian against a
scene
this one looks to be going b brian's way
he's gonna get a touchdown
check here yeah everything's
everything's nice and
comfortable for black
on pison on the way
all right white resigns that one let's
check out another
or not that was the last game
okay i know who i'm getting this time
the kid who plays the kid has only
slipped up once
against this guy malapost
who's in who went into pause mode
okay
yes oh yeah you're right that's when i
started
you know the justin tv days
yeah it started as that and then it
switched over
actually the first the first spot i was
streaming was you
you stream uh there wasn't
obs wasn't even a thing at the time
i had to do some roundabout
uh setup adobe
some adobe flash
program cam cam twist
program now it's now it's so much easier
obs in your your golden
alright the kid who plays the kid should
i be surprised here
all right we got we got the kid playing
the kid
i like i like meeting e5 immediately
with d5
what do they call that the move
petrosian would be proud of the trojan
petrossian system okay
knight here right now because
i want to stop knight to h5
in case this guy gets kicked around the
knight tries to get in here i like
having a
a direct shot on that guy now
ah let's be aggressive let's go with h4
caveman attack caveman variation
i'm making that up
if i could get this and then that i'm
really happy about
black not getting it f5 in so easily
maybe it could work
tactically but here we go
this is you don't have to flinch here is
the thing
okay this was still a move because if i
take my bishop gets squashed so this is
this is a really big deal
things have changed quite a bit these
last two moves
the character of the position could have
changed with a different
12th move by black so now i have an
opportunity to stop f5 for good
and turn this into a long
strategic battle that will likely ensue
on the queen side
where i have space so there's still a
pawn break i need to watch out for
c6 things can't open up over here but
this one should be under control by me
for the duration of the game ideally i
want this exchange in
and a knight on f5 this guy is kind of
dead for the whole game there i've seen
this maneuver
but that takes quite a bit of tempe
also gone for this but that's going to
take some time as well
first things first um
do i castle
play a3
f3 not castle
i'll go with castles first
moved a lot of pawns in front of my king
but
i do not foresee this position opening
up on the king's side
it is locked
so eventually i could go for this kind
of stuff i may want to baby step it
though
i have to be careful of chop chop and b5
so these kind of moves may be
threatening
this advance because then my knight gets
pushed around
so i may have to insert a4
which gives up a really big square on b4
not quite sure okay they're taking first
i want to maintain a pawn on this square
so this is
i think this is very helpful to me
because now i have the c4 square
for my knight which can play a nice roll
like knight c4 into b6 is grabbing my
attention
let's begin with putting a rook on the
only open file just like black did
yeah and now that knight right there
is without question their best piece so
i'm going to try and get rid of it i
have a space
so you know
normally i would want to keep these
exchanges to a minimum
but uh i think in order to make some
progress i need to initiate some
exchange this knight is just way too
good
and these attempts to try and get in b4
i think
are not so practical okay
maybe i ducked the exchange now i don't
i don't know okay well
if i take here no i'm not really too
concerned about that
uh i'll take with the knight i'm gonna
take towards the center
i could get the light square bishops off
so they're actually considering
taking with the the pawn i have a passer
but their knight finally has a decent
square
okay that's what they're going for so
now timing is very important these guys
right here could turn out to be an
unhealthy three versus two i could clamp
down with a4 i think it's very important
i play this move
right now and ensure
i get the light square bishops off
and long term i'm looking to do a
slithering along the light squares i'm
not sure how i'm gonna
pull that off exactly
yeah i'm not really sure how i'm gonna
manage that
let's do this first so my queen doesn't
have to constantly babysit this
this pawn uh how to make progress
it's not easy
start with queen here
i'm not so sure i can make progress here
i mean they allow me to get this in
it's an interesting decision for sure
taking away from the center
that night a square okay now
now i could get this in and i don't have
to end up with double isolated b-pawns
so i think this last move helped me i
want to get rid of their knight for sure
the thing is though i don't i still
don't have a pawn break
maybe maybe tactically i have some pawn
break
so i could i could clamp down entirely
on these light squares now
but how do i actually make progress
is the thing i really don't see a way to
make progress
it improved my king
maybe this if there's the their queen is
unprotected
sneak my king over a little bit
right here are there any tricks yet no
yeah i'm i'm not really sure
can i try anything over here
let me hint at some trick here possibly
a trick there
maybe fight against the c4 move
i do have an idea
i'm not even threatening that
all right i'm gonna have to try
something else um do i have any tricks
what about this timely break is there
any any timely break on the king side
this isn't one of these where i'm trying
to win on time especially with the
increment
hmm
could try to still be sneaky let's go
here hang on
i think my rook belongs on b5 let me get
him back there
we might be at the 50 move mark soon
setting up something sneaky
queen corner pocket okay i have an
opportunity for b4 i want my king a
little cozier though okay they
i just missed my opportunity huh it was
an hour never moment
all right is there anything over here
[Music]
hmm
it's just a little too locked
yeah um let me play some more moves i'm
still trying to fish for something
risking losing on time
they have a they have a perfect setup
yeah the sacrifice on a a a5 is just not
there
and i'm not seeing it
yeah i'll accept okay good game
[Music]
got a little too locked
wow i really have to scroll back to when
there was a pawn move
huh needed to do something else right
around here
a4 well if i'm not playing a4 then
there's this yeah i don't know
that was kind of tough good game no
let's go back uh
here we go all right so we are
final round now
i think i'm gonna get b brian
uh one of these two actually because i
already played doctor of love
just a little too locked a lot too long
okay be brian we played the sicilian
just before i
the first game of the stream was against
b brian
it was a sicilian
i'm not gonna play the sicilian this
time
let's do something else how about the
scandinavian
what do you got all right queen d6
quick 65 thank you for the host
better biscuit thank you for the prime
sub
and team edge thank you for the tier one
resub
you beast 65
months in a row you add hope you're well
hope you've been
well jerry happy holidays yes thank you
and same to you
a questioned ferrari in any tournaments
lately i haven't seen the ferrari in a
little bit
it's probably been a few months since uh
we played
let's back off just a
tick just in case
that move is hitting
so basically black's gonna be
a little bit worse for a while but
enjoys having a nice compact structure
free free of what
yeah solid structure free of free of any
weaknesses i may
this knight is a real bug i'm gonna
just give the bishop up if you play the
scandinavian the karakon
you're you're okay with giving up your
light square bishop for a night
okay so who's gonna give an inch
this position is a game of inches
so i think i'm gonna go same-sides
castling
one two points unprotected
can't strike at them both in one swing
potential checks
how do i want to arrange my pawns i
really don't want to fix my pawns on a
light square
this h5 may be tempting to get in h4 but
it'll be stopped cold and this guy's
eyes will light up
the future can be protected but then
that
that means i have uh more pawns on light
squares so
that's that means there are prospects
for the bishop
all right oh i i think this is the id
they want to they wanna simply back that
bishop
up i understand now
see i'm not sure what i should even do
here what's my
what's my big bad plan how about we put
this knight on his favorite square
i wouldn't mind seeing this exchange so
i don't think they should allow it
bishop on f3 does a good job of simply
controlling my knight and then
some sees further
the bishop is superior tonight in this
way with this configuration
all right
let's flick in this h6 move stops queen
g5 and maybe hints at playing g5 g4
maybe let's go here
here double up see how they react to the
pressure how about this yeah
so something like this i'm i'm coming up
with
some basic plan right
it involves logical moves boom
boom boom put pressure on a pawn
about that boom
maybe even go here king b1
simple enough defense okay so
i have ways to break um proceed with
caution if i'm going to play this
because that extends the scope of the
bishop
still i think this guy belongs here
it's very very solid for both sides i
feel
no weaknesses on either end okay you're
okay with a queen exchange
if i go here i wouldn't mind seeing a
queen exchange let's see
they have the queens off okay i like
that
now how do things change are there any
new ideas that are now available without
the queens on almost certainly
i could feel more comfortable playing
here without the queen
taking advantage of the dark square gaps
on the queen side this is
not really uh i don't know
well let's let's go here why though
let's see if they take why not okay what
am i okay so
now now things are changing a little bit
in my
favor maybe because i could potentially
saddle white with a
a target on the queen side this seems
very natural but i'm going to take here
so i have this long-term plan of
creating a target in white's position
i may also want to insert this move
while i have the
chance yeah i don't want to see h5 that
can be
kind of cramping okay so now
i'm thinking of this kind of maneuver my
king has a path on these light squares
they could make it difficult for me
but this would you know they could stop
king to f5
but this is going to require the
attention of a full rook
to satisfy that uh
you know to to to ward off this plan of
getting into the g3
pawn
so i like my position and this rook
specific
ending i should get here right away
right away do i play this move
yeah i i i don't want it to get too
locked up now
okay i hear i could still pry open the a
file okay
here i'm going for this little hunt
ready to hunt the g pawn now you don't
want to trade too much
gonna need a rook around to defend g3
so let's see it's a lengthy one
let's play a little faster huh okay
i could i could play this though yo
why did i need to have that move in i
don't know
now it's required to get this break in
okay i'm anticipating one rook off and i
want to have this guy around to uh
okay i gotta get this break in finally
they're in a giant pickle are they not
king enters am i going to get mated
here here here
it's a little scary but i don't see them
weaving a mate
um
i've gone too far that rook is perfect
for defending
oh here i have this
i'm also defending do i have
oh they giving me a window is my rook in
time to catch the pawns
so it's not calculated
wow
i think the two pawns are outweighing
the rook here just barely
by a tempo i'm winning this by a tempo
oh man
lucky
buy a tempo
wow clearly not calculated
rolling the dice there could have been
losing
for sure two pawns on the seventh
and the second will outweigh that rook
i just was not realizing good game b
brian i i just was not realizing how
efficient your rook would be with one
rook
being exchanged i mean
i needed to play it a little differently
here in the end that rook was
made my king look ridiculous and i think
a different approach here like improving
the king first and only doing this
because i'm i'm kind of stuck i have to
watch this i
if i'm to get some pawn break over here
i have to have this pawn supported
i could try this this is too long-winded
though and
it feels like
here and i'm gonna be in trouble what's
the analysis saying right around here
should like white says it's equal feels
like it's much easier for me to slip
up somehow
when is it losing is it ever losing for
me
it says still equal
it's a draw still a draw
how do i interpret that
brook b5 check okay a timely rook move
is necessary
now i'm now i'm winning with e3
but that's a draw
okay yeah i wasn't gonna this is one of
those eenie meenie miney mo
moments flip a coin which one do i go
with first
so that's the win or excuse me this is
the win because
after this there's a check here
and then the rook gets to play here
whereas this check a king here and
you're not able to get here
behind the pawn okay that's interesting
in the end after the king move it is i
guess
well it's lost after this king move okay
yeah
tough to figure that out with just
seconds on the clock
okay that is the final round there we go
thank you all for playing here's your
top three got first there with eight and
a half
the kid who plays the kid
kept me from getting nine out of nine
good game the kid
who plays the kid copious
blunders taking third be brian
fourth there's your top ten
again if you're interested in competing
in the swiss style tournaments
on the weekends i have them scheduled
anyone is free to enter as long as
you're
part of the team you're able to go in
this area right here
and uh yeah you could track it down once
you're on my profile here
leadchest.org forward slash team forward
slash chess network
and you can see what's upcoming go to
the tournaments
what's completed what's upcoming
and jump in so that i've been scheduling
rape uh
rated rapid and rated
blitz nine rounds of three two
and five rounds of ten one
as you can see here okay let me go back
here good games
to everyone who played let's check out
everyone here
73 in there for this one
okay
good games oh
i like i like the swiss tournaments
they're much more laid back
you